Etienne Bacro contre Dieu c'est le match
qu'on attendait tant est-ce que bah qui
peut dominer Dieu ou pas ça son nom de
famille quoi c'est ce que j'ai trois
Dieu qui veut qui veut faire un fiancé
donc il y a eu petit rock ici cavalier à
4 il veut toucher la casser 5 Dieu se
bat face à ce diablotin de baquis à deux
il y a tombé 8 fois 6 peut-être que Dieu
peut la gagner ton premier 5 puis on
prend il y aurait fou prends à 7 si Dieu
a tombé 5
oh il l'a pas oh là une casse près dieu
est grand dans cette partie ah il va
devoir faire camaïeu hein bah qui qui
doit prendre la nul contre Dieu tu as
l'air d'être dangereux pour pour Dieu là
parce que le pion il avance pas
malheureusement tu auras 4 oh il y a
cavalier F3 Dieu qui se prend une
fourchette Dieu qui se prend la
fourchette oh c'est terrible terrible
image Dieu qui s'inquine face à Baki il
était pas loin il était pas loin quelle
partie il a joué
[Musique]